all guidance was followed uh completely
during number 10. in this building on
Wednesday a crucial moment in Boris
Johnson's political career a multi-hour
interrogation by the Privileges
committee into whether he misled MPS
while prime minister there was no party
and that and that no covid rules were
broken these statements turned out to be
false when it's just but did Boris
Johnson know that at the time his team
claimed not and say he'll be Vindicated
government ministers trying to stay out
of the row
I'm sure Boris Johnson will give a
robust defense of himself and then it
would be for the committee to to
determine the outcome of it it's not
helpful is it though
well this is a process that was
initiated by the House of Commons and of
course the house comes is entirely at
Liberty to to make whatever decisions it
it wants to so how will it work an
interim committee report said it should
have been obvious to Boris Johnson that
rules were being broken the former prime
minister's defense will be published
tomorrow that's likely to include advice
he was given at the time the committee
which has a majority of Tory MPS on it
will then cross-examine Mr Johnson on
Wednesday they will then decide whether
he misled the house and if so whether he
should be suspended any sanction will
have to be approved by MPS and tories
won't be forced to vote one way or the
other
allies of Boris Johnson have spent
months trying to discredit the
investigation accusing the chair the
senior labor MP Harriet Harman of having
already made her mind up and suggesting
the Tories on the committee have grudges
against the former prime minister it all
means that any Commons vote could be a
moment where the Deep divisions in the
conservative party are once again opened
up for all to see
the inquiry could even cost Boris
Johnson his West London seat if a
lengthy suspension is handed down he may
have to fight a by-election to hang on
to his place in the Commons
opposition parties clear Which Way
they'd like that vote to go Boris
Johnson's days should be numbered he's a
discredited prime minister his
discredited politician and he needs to
be held to account just like the whole
of the conservative party they supported
Boris Johnson to be prime minister they
allowed him to lie continually
events here on Wednesday will play out
as Rishi sunak puts his brexit deal to a
vote in the Commons for the first time
drama around Boris Johnson once again
obscuring the government's political
priorities Rob pal Sky News in
Westminster